[Music]
a teacher at a Valley Middle School
fired over an alleged racial incident
thank you for joining us at 4 I'm
Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian loft is now
School administrators were quick to take
action after launching an investigation
it happened at Sylvester junior high
school that is in the South part of town
right along Silverado Ranch Boulevard
near Maryland Parkway and that is where
our education reporter
Gara joins us now with the details
Joshua
Joshua hello Brian Kristen the teacher
was a substitute and he used racially
insensitive language as part of a lesson
plan and less than 24 hours later CCSD
fired him
we're told from a guardian that during
an English class A teacher wrote the
n-word several times on a whiteboard
this is a picture captured by students
of that lesson we have blur the racial
slurs and the teachers face there's
really no excuse for this
there should not be any type of lesson
around the n-word
um so it's really appalling and it's
hurtful Camila bywaters is the National
Action Network says there is a lack of
anti-racism training for staff at CCSD
and firing the sub doesn't solve the
problem but it's not enough we continue
to continuing to see this culture of
racial insensitivity we're continuing to
see this culture of violence towards
black students within our schools in an
email sent to students and parents
Silvestri principal Yvette tippetts says
I would like to inform you at the school
administration became aware of an
incident on our campus that involved
communication that contained racial
implications the principle adds in part
we will not tolerate behaviors that
contradict an inclusive community
yeah
now that principle also thanked the
students who brought this issue to the
attention of Staff reporting live at
Silvestri Junior High School Joshua
peguero eight news now
thank you Joshua CCSD also says the sub
is no longer employable for the district
and the district reminds and encourages
all students to make reports through
safe voice the anonymous reporting
system